wir kommen zum kanadischen Sniper Vali
das ist sein kriegsname er wird zu einem
Mythos im Ukraine Krieg kämpft unter
anderem in mariopol und immer an der
Seite der Ukraine jetzt wird er
Kommandeur einer neuen
scharfschützeneinheit
[Musik]
er legt sich wieder auf die Lauer der
derzeit berühmteste Scharfschütze der
Welt tarname Wally der Kanadier kämpfte
als Scharfschütze in Afghanistan und
gegen is-terroristen gleich nach
Kriegsbeginn in der Ukraine meldete
Wally sich zum Kampf gegen Putins
Truppen wurde sogar von Moskau aus
Propagandamaschine als Tod gemeldet eine
Lüge jetzt nach rund fünf Monaten Pause
ist er zurück
das letzte Mal als ich in der Ukraine
war bin ich hingefahren um das Land zu
verteidigen beim Einsatz jetzt gehe ich
in die Offensive all die Orte wo ich war
Therapien Butcher all diese Orte wurden
jetzt befreit es gibt da keine Russen
mehr das ist sehr befriedigend
ich bin jetzt hier in Kiew und es ist
als gelbes keinen Krieg ich kann nachts
Sushi bestellen Bier trinken Freunde
treffen aber jetzt haben die Verteidiger
der Ukraine ein anderes Problem zu viele
Schafe zu wenig Wölfen
die Truppen wurden im Krieg
zusammengewürfelt und nie richtig
ausgebildet die brauchen Training sie
müssen von erfahrenen Leuten geleitet
werden ich bin jetzt also Kommandeur
einer scharfschützeneinheit die Idee ist
quasi mich selbst zu Klone ein Wally ist
gut aber es ist doch viel besser viele
Wallys auf den Schlachtfeldern zu haben
nach seinen blutigen Kampfeinsätzen
hatte Bildreporter Herbert Bauer Nebel
den super Sniper in den kanadischen
Wäldern getroffen sein Rückzugsort zum
Kraft sammeln und eine Chance die
Familie zu besuchen die er jetzt wieder
zurückgelassen hat
ja die Familie zurückzulassen war das
härteste bei meinen ersten Einsätzen
hatte ich noch keine Familie keinen Sohn
keine Frau das war viel leichter aber es
ist notwendig
aus den kanadischen Wäldern zurück in
die Ukraine eine große Auszeichnung für
wall- die Ukraine vertraut dem Kämpfer
aus dem Ausland stellt 150 Soldaten
unter seinen Kommando eine riesige
Umgewöhnung für den 40-Jährigen denn mit
kämpfen und Adrenalin hat der neue Job
erstmal nichts zu tun
mein Leben besteht daraus durch die
Stadt zu gehen Leute zu treffen Dinge zu
arrangieren die scharfschützeneinheit
existiert ja noch gar nicht richtig ein
Teil steht aber vieles eben noch nicht
wir mussten bei Null anfangen
Zeit zum Aufatmen zumal die Ukraine
aktuell viele Gebiete zurückgewinnt
[Musik]
s and hills das sind sehr bedeutende
Erfolge der Grund ist dieser als die
Russen in die Ukraine einmarschiert sind
haben sie leeres Land besetzt die
Menschen waren alle geflohen die sind
ohne Gegner in den Boxring gestiegen
[Musik]
darum haben sie gewonnen jetzt ist es so
dass die Ukraine zum ersten Mal Kämpfer
in den Boxring geschickt hat und zwar
schnell und effektiv das heißt das
können wir wieder schaffen
doch russland will nachrüsten die
Mobilmachung von 300.000 treservisten
für den Helden Sniper kein
erfolgskonzeptiert
nach und nach seine besten Karten aus er
pokert mit der Zukunft Russlands ich
denke die Mobilisierung wird nicht
erfolgreich sein Grund eins viele Russen
fliehen aus dem Land sie sind nicht
glücklich mit der teilmobilisierung und
selbst wenn sie kämpfen wollten wäre das
nicht einfach du musst die Truppen
trainieren du brauchst Ausrüstung du
musst die transportieren allein für die
Ausbildung musst du erfahrene Kämpfer
von der Front abziehen
erfahrene Kämpfer wie ihn doch er kämpft
nicht für Russland Wally kämpft für die
Ukraine in einer ganz neuen Brigade was
ist
super
ja es wird die 47 Brigade eine
angriffsbrigade die Hauptaufgabe dieser
Brigade wird es dann sein die Frontlinie
zu durchbrechen und Teil dieser Brigade
wird dann die scharfschützeneinheit sein
etwa 150 Mann die ich dann kommandiere
die Idee ist es das schwer zu schärfen
bevor man es benutzt so die allies
Training ich werde die Soldaten so
effektiv trainieren wie es geht mit der
Zeit und Ausrüstung die wir haben und
weil ich in erster Linie selbst Soldat
bin will ich mir auch die Hände dreckig
machen und selbst an die Familie
die Aussage ist klar nur organisieren
und Leute trainieren reicht ihm nicht
dem berühmtesten Scharfschützen der Welt
[Musik]